creating high quality photorealistic
materials for light transport
simulations typically includes direct
hands-on interaction with a principal
shader this means that the user has to
tweak a large number of material
properties by hand and has to wait for a
new image of it to be rendered after
each interaction this requires a fair
bit of expertise and the best setups are
often obtained through a lengthy trial
and error process to enhance this
workflow we present a learning-based
system for rapid masc material synthesis
first the user is presented with the
gallery of materials and the assigned
scores are shown in the upper left here
we learn the concept of glassy and
transparent materials by learning on
only a few tenths of high-scoring
samples our system is able to recommend
many new materials from the learn
distributions the learning step
typically takes a few seconds where the
recommendations take negligible time and
can be done on a mass scale then these
recommendations can be used to populate
a scene with materials typically each
recommendation takes 40 to 60 seconds to
render with global illumination which is
clearly unacceptable for real-world
workflows even for mid-sized galleries
in the next step we propose a
convolutional neural network that is
able to predict images of these
materials that are close to the ones
generated via a global illumination and
takes less than three milliseconds per
image sometimes a recommended material
is close to the one envisioned by the
user but requires a bit of fine-tuning
to this end we embed our high
dimensional shader descriptors into an
intuitive to the latent space where
exploration and adjustments can take
place without any domain expertise
however this isn't very useful without
additional information because the user
does not know which regions offer useful
material models that are in line with
their scores one of our key observations
is that this latent space technique can
be combined with Gaussian process
regression to provide an intuitive color
coding of the expected preferences to
help highlighting the regions that may
be of interest furthermore our
convolutional neural network can also
provide real-time predictions of these
images these predictions are close to
indistinguishable from the real rendered
image
and are generated in real time
beyond the preference map this neural
network also opens up the possibility of
visualizing the expected similarity of
these new materials to the one we seek
to fine-tune by combining the preference
and similarity maps we obtain a color
coding that guides the user in this
latent space towards materials that are
both similar and have a high expected
score
to accentuate the utility of our real
time variant generation technique we
show a practical case where one of the
great materials is almost done but
requires a slight reduction in VV DT
this adjustment doesn't require any
domain expertise or direct interaction
with the material modeling system and
can be done in real time
in this example we learned the concept
of translucent materials from only a
handful of high-scoring samples and
generate a large amount of
recommendations from the learned
distribution
you
these recommendations can then be used
to populate a scene with relevant
materials
here we show the preference and
similarity maps of the learned
translucent material space and explore
possible variants of an input material
you
these recommendations can be used for
masking material synthesis and the
amount of variation can be tweaked to
suit the users artistic vision
after assigning the appropriate
materials displacements and other
advanced effects can be easily added to
these materials
we have also experimented with an
extended more expressive version of our
shader that also includes procedural
textured al beetles and displacements
the following scenes were populated
using the material learning and
recommendation and latent space
embedding steps we have proposed a
system for mass scale material synthesis
that is able to rapidly recommend a
broad range of new material models after
learning the user preferences from a
modest number of samples beyond this
pipeline we also explored powerful
combinations of the three used learning
algorithms thereby opening up the
possibility of real-time photorealistic
material visualization exploration and
fine tuning in a 2d latent space we
believe this feature set offers a useful
solution for rapid masking material
synthesis for novice and expert users
alike and hope to see more exploratory
works combining the advantages of
multiple state-of-the-art learning
algorithms in the future